hier krabbelt eine spinne aus dem tablet
und hier fließt das bier in strömen
seit fünf jahren ist simon pierro als
der ipad zauberer bekannt
das ist die neueste technologie
es geht schnell es ist billig und vor
allem tut es nicht weh
die digitalen illusionen gelingen nur
weil simon pierro das klassische magier
handwerk beherrscht fingerfertigkeit
ablenkung und perfektes timing
zusammen mit software entwickler masashi
behaim arbeitet er an neuen tricks bei
der programmierung kommt es auf kleinste
details an die digitale zauberkunst
kommt ohne programmierung nicht aus
ich dachte sich nicht zu viel verraten
von meinen geheimnissen alles ganz klar
ich kombiniere geschickte darstellung
auf dem ipad grafische art die natürlich
auch einfacher programmiert sind mit
fingerfertigkeiten damit ich mein stift
nicht verliere hinter lege ich den immer
hier auf der dritten seite
so und jetzt kann ich wieder zeit habe
ich darauf wieder zugriff simon pierro
arbeitet ständig an neuen tricks und
show idee und sorgt dafür dass die
zauberei auch im digitalen zeitalter
millionen menschen faszinieren
es ist unglaublich sehr interessant
keine ahnung wie es macht ich will es
auch gar nicht wissen
einfach cool mehr als 20 millionen mal
wurden seine videos angesehen
der zauberer hat tv auftritte weltweit
tolle sachen machen können
aber wem haben sie gezeigt ich hatte das
glück dass sie in deutschland im
fernsehen
in der fernsehshow der primetime show
regelmäßig dabei war aber nicht zu
vergleichen mit den auswirkungen
facebook da für mich war und einige
seiner zaubertricks funktionieren sogar
auf dem smartphone